and I should say our arts and
entertainment correspondent Lucy
Cotton's report has some flash
photography in it this is what happens
when Hollywood takes over the high
courts a list that actor Johnny Depp who
spent the last 30 years walking the red
carpet still managed to play to the
crowd as he began his libel action
against the Sun newspapers publishers
the case revolves around his ex-wife
Amber Heard and an article in the Sun
which described death as a wife beater
alleging the actor was violent towards
hurt something he strenuously denies in
the opening arguments Depp's lawyers
argued misheard invented stories of
serious violence saying he's not and
never has been a wife-beater
indeed Depp says it was misheard who was
the one who started physical fights who
punched and hit him she was the abuser
not him
the Sun newspaper groups legal team are
relying on 14 alleged incidents of abuse
which say mr. Depp was controlling and
verbally and physically abusive towards
Miss heard particularly when he was
under the influence of alcohol and/or
drugs Depp was the first to give
evidence here and while on the witness
stand he was asked repeatedly whether he
had anger management issues something he
denied debt was also proved repeatedly
about his drug and alcohol misuse he
admitted he took drugs for the first
time aged just 11 and had tried every
substance known to man just three years
later the actor also said that because
of abuse in his childhood he turned away
from violence and preferred to avoid
confrontation always aspiring to be a
Southern gentleman
Amber Heard lawyers however are painting
a picture of a domestic abuser who would
refer to himself as the monster when he
attacked her while giving evidence Depp
was asked if he appeared to be violent
in a video shown to the court of him and
heard and he said I was violent with
some cupboards clearly I wasn't in the
best state of mind Depp is due to give
evidence for the next two days in this
blockbuster
which Amber Heard says she never wanted
at stake his reputation and career
Lucy Cotter Sky News